JENNY MURPHY: Hi everyone.
Welcome to this week's session
of the Google+
Platform Office hours.
This week we're joined by the
Tabletop top forage Team, and
they're going to tell us about
their experiences developing
this really cool Hangout app.
And we're also going
to see a demo.
So before we get going, I'll
just introduce myself and
everyone around me.
I'm Jenny Murphy.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer here at Google on the
Google+ platform.
And next to me--
JONATHAN BERRY: Jonathan Berry,
I'm the developer
advocate for Google+
Hangout apps.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: And
I'm Will Thomson.
I'm a developer program
engineer on
Hangout apps, as well.
JENNY MURPHY: And then behind
the camera, Shrag is helping
us with audio video stuff.
It looks like he's going to come
over and do a lean in.
There you go.
There is someone behind
the camera.
Ya, Shrag!
And joining us, via the magic
of Hangouts, we have Allen.
ALLEN: Hi there.
JENNY MURPHY: We have Charles.
CHARLES: Hey.
JENNY MURPHY: Joshua.
JOSHUA: Hello.
JENNY MURPHY: And Frasier.
FRASIER: Hi everybody.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
OK, so I guess we might as
well get started with the
demo, and we'll check
out this cool app.
And then we will barrage
you questions.
Charles, I think you
were going to be
doing the demo screen.
Fire it on up.
CHARLES: Alright, let me
screen-share this.
So can everybody see that?
JENNY MURPHY: Yep,
so we see a map.
And those of you on-air may not
be able to see the texts,
but you'll just have
to trust us that
there's text there, too.
We'll talk you through it.
JONATHAN BERRY: So before you
get into the screen share, why
don't you give us a little
overview of what you built.
CHARLES: OK, well so it's a
little bit complicated.
Josh and I both started building
same app, basically.
And we started talking about
building our app, and we
started talking about how we
were both doing it, and
talking to the community that
already exists in Google+ of
role playing gamers.
And every time we talked, we
kind of realized that were
doing the same thing slightly
differently.
It was kind of like convergent
evolution, he's making a shark
and I'm making a dolphin, but
they both end up looking
pretty much the same.
So I can't speak for Josh, but
I certainly came to the
realization that there was too
much here to do for just me in
my spare time, because I'm
a programmer full time.
And that takes up a fair chunk
of my time, and I'm a dad when
I'm not doing that.
So we've decided to just pool
our efforts and build one app
that serves the needs
of the community.
So we're building a role playing
game, or RPG app, that
lets people play RPGs
in the Hangouts.
So I guess the most
commonly known RPG
is Dungeons & Dragons.
It's a game in which one person
creates a world with
The Lord of the Rings kind of
world, and everybody plays a
character in that world, Gimli
or one of the elves, or one of
the hobbits.
And so you go around, and you
have adventures, and you do
various different things that
your character is able to do,
and some characters are good
at some things, and other
characters are good at other
things, and you explore, and
you become more powerful,
and so on, and so forth.
But really what it is, it's a
shared tactical game, but it's
also a shared storytelling
experience.
One person comes up with the
overarching world, and
everybody else figures out how
they're going to behave in
that world, how they're going to
interact in that world, how
they're going to make themselves
part of that world.
So it's a really creative
set of games.
So RPGs are not just a game,
they're a set of games.
Some of them are set in our
world, in an alternate version
of our world, in the future,
the past, in a
galaxy far, far away.
The most commonly known ones,
like Dungeons & Dragons, are
set in a medieval fantasy
setting, mostly pilfered from
The Lord of the Rings.
There are post apocalyptic ones,
and so on, and so forth.
So with any world you can
imagine you mix some worlds
and throw people into it, and
then you pretend that you're
walking around the world.
So normally what's done for
this style of game is that
there is a table in between the
players, or around which
the players gather.
And sometimes there's a map,
sometimes they'll have tokens
to represent yourself moving
around on the map.
And almost always you'll have
dice, or in some cases cards
that you draw randomly to
determine how well you succeed
or fail doing something.
So the two main components of
a table top when you're
playing are the ability to roll
dice, where everybody can
see you roll the dice, so you
can't cheat, and say you got
something you didn't get.
And, in a lot of cases the
ability to put up a map, and
then move around the map.
In some cases you want to put
up pictures to give people a
feeling of what they see, or
what they're interacting with.
But in any case it comes down
to an image that is in a
shared environment.
And so that's why Hangouts
are so good for this.
A lot of people have been making
virtual table tops for
a lot of years, but in most of
you can't see each other, you
don't have that shared
videoconferencing, you have
some degree of sharing the same
elements, the map, or the
rolling of the dice.
You can text each other.
But, in my opinion, and Josh
can maybe speak to this a
little more, Google Hangouts
really just gives you the
whole package.
It gives you the ability to see
everybody, as if you're
sitting around the same table.
It gives you the ability to
create a space where you can
all interact with the same
elements, as if you're all
rolling the same dice, or
looking at the same map.
So that's, I guess, the
starting of it.
So what I've put up here in
the app is a map that I've
uploaded, that I didn't draw.
I believe this one is
from Fantastic Maps.
Jonathan is a fantastic
map drawer.
And so this is, I believe,
this a chunk of his.
And on the right hand side is
the window where we have
rebuilt the chat function with
some of added functionalities.
So you can roll dice
in the chat window.
So you type /d and then
you type in what
dice you want to roll.
I want to roll two six sided
dice, so I write 2D6, and I've
got a bonus plus 3, so I go
plus 3, and I roll it.
And I don't know if you can see
it in this resolution, but
I rolled a 9 out of 12.
JONATHAN BERRY: I love that.
CHARLES: And so now I'm trying
to do something, I need an
eight, I roll a nine,
everybody's happy, I've
succeeded in doing it,
and we carry on.
If I'd rolled the dice
on my desktop.
I would have had to point my
camera at my desktop, or you'd
just all had to have taken
my word for it.
And more often than not, if I
really needed to make the
roll, I'd just lie, and tell
you that I'd done it.
JONATHAN BERRY: And
we have done that.
We've taken the camera, and
joined a hangout with an extra
account, pointed the camera at
the table, and I was rolling
dice to show for everybody.
And you can see it
on the camera.
But this is a much more
elegant solution.
CHARLES: I don't know why they
don't just trust me and accept
that I got what I rolled.
ALLEN: Speaking of trust,
speaking of trust, can I ask a
quick technical question
at this point?
That die roll, is that taking
place on your machine, on the
DM's machine, from Central
server, or where exactly did
that take place, and how does
everyone else trust that?
JOSHUA: So right now it does
take place on the client, so
theoretically if somebody really
want to know what they
were doing and hack JavaScript
files, they can mess with it.
But the event syncing that
senses the other clients
through the Google state
object uses a certain
formatting of the messaging
that might be hard to
reproduce if they didn't know
what they were doing.
Eventually, I mean we are doing
some stuff server side
for handling local files and
stuff like that, so it
wouldn't be too hard to move
the random number generator
part of that to the server,
but for now we're trusting
that no one's messing around
with the clients.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: If it's
Dungeons and Dragons, you
could always be like, and a rock
falls out of the sky and
crushes you.
CHARLES: Exactly.
Well you know this is actually
a case of an example of the
convergent evolution
that we had.
And this is why when Josh and
I finally decided to work
together, we went through
this a few times, trying
to merge our work.
But once you get under the skin,
we realized that how we
were doing it was
quite different.
Every time it just seemed
like too much trouble.
So Josh is doing this, I
believe, in JavaScript all in
the client side.
What I was doing was I was
posting about JSON to an
Apache server, and running PHP
to parche the text and to come
up with the random die results,
and then posting that
back and to the client, and
from there into the shared
state, and then pushing
it to everybody else.
So two totally different ways
of doing exactly the same
thing, but when it came down to
an integrating one with the
other, it was just apples
and oranges.
ALLEN: And that's part of why
I asked the question is
because there are obviously a
lot of different approaches
that can go with it.
I want to know which one you
guys chose, and kind of your
thinking behind why
you chose that.
And especially when you're
talking games, how do you find
the right a comfort level
between security and
playability.
JOSHUA: Right, OK so for the
main mechanism of how we're
actually sharing everything,
first of all, we are using the
shared state objects.
It does have a limit of the 10K
size, so we actually don't
share when you add
an image there.
We just share the event that
player X added an image, and
then in the shared state object
we share out the URL,
the size of image, the location
of the image, and we
essentially replay that
on all of the clients.
So we're using the state
object kind of
like an event engine.
And as soon as it processes that
event from that person,
it clears it from the state.
CHARLES: So the two aspects of
this is that are that you've
got a limit of 10K in the shared
state, which needs to
be very conservative about what
you put in there, and you
have to clean it up when
you're done with it.
And then the other thing is,
that because there's so many
browsers, cross browser
compatibility becomes a big
issue, which is why I chose
to go the JSON PHP route.
Because once you're at PHP,
you're on a server that's
completely separate.
You know what the environment
is, and it always works the
same every single time.
As long as you can do the JSON
event, and parse the result on
every browser, it doesn't
matter what it
is that you're doing.
So we're still in the process
of working this out.
The Tabletop Forge has turned
out to be remarkably stable.
But these are, obviously,
questions that we're going to
be asking every single time
we do anything in here.
And the more complex it gets,
the more we're going to have
to examine those things.
JONATHAN BERRY: So I think last
week you asked a similar
question about security,
especially about storing local
config files.
So in games it's interesting,
because no matter how smart
you want to be with the
JavaScript, you
can always hack it.
You can obfuscate it, you can
encrypt it, but at the end of
the day, you can't trust it.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: Everybody
can read your files.
JONATHAN BERRY: Everybody can
read the files, and then if
you're doing shared state stuff,
then you can maybe even
read the files, or change
people's files
on their own apps.
So the way games specifically
do it, they actually have a
server that models
the entire world.
So they have a state of
everything stored.
Every player, their values,
their turns, and then when
somebody wants to make a move,
you request that server,
saying is this a valid move?
You know, I trust you.
And then you go back
and forth.
So that's more secure
way of doing things.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: You guys also
have, especially with the
dice, you have an event
tracker there.
And even if somebody goes in and
changes your shared state,
each client has a record
of what's going on.
So ultimately, because
transactional that way, you
can walk back up the
transactions and see if
somebody was cheating.
CHARLES: The thing, too, is that
I wrestled with these,
and I'm sure Josh has as well,
we're trying to model reality.
And in reality you can put
your finger on the
die and tip it over.
You can put your hand up so
that people don't see what
you're doing.
You could move the pieces of
paper back off the map so you
can see in rooms that you
actually haven't explored yet.
At some point it ruins
the game to do that.
If your going to have people
cheating, they're going to
find a way to cheat, anyways.
And because we're not building
a game system, we're building
a system for a whole
host of games.
Some of which use maps, some of
which use tokens, some of
which use dice, some
of which use cards.
The more you lock it down, the
more you exclude some games,
and make it so it only works
with other games.
My personal goal is to lock it
down as much as you can to
ensure that what somebody does
is what everybody sees.
But then beyond that to leave
it as loose as possible, to
that works for everyone.
And then you just
trust people.
If the GM gets up and goes to
the bathroom and comes back he
just trusts that nobody's
looked at the map.
There's not that somebody's
there as a
guard to watch that.
ALLEN: Well I think that--
CHARLES: We trust that you
haven't taken six hours to
figure out how to reverse
engineer the program and you
always get a good roll.
It ruins the game for the
players as much as it ruins
the game for the GM.
ALLEN: And I think that that's
an important point.
Most of the games that we're
talking about right now are
social games.
And if you rig the game so
that it's always in your
favor, people just aren't
going to want
to play with you.
If you're always rolling six on
a D6, people are going to
say, meh, why do I want to play
with this guy anyway?
CHARLES: Yeah, I was going to
share this later, but I'll
share this now, actually,
because it fits in with what
we're talking about here.
This is one of the next things
that we're working on, it's
called the fog of war.
So it's the equivalent of
putting down pieces of paper
over a top of a map that
has more than the
players explored on it.
So this is a map with, let's
say, four players and the X is
meant to represent some extra
person who isn't actually a
player, but he's along for the
ride, a non-player character.
And this shows where
everybody is.
Bruce Cordell is the
blue person, I'm in
there over to the right.
And this is what we've
all discovered.
We've found this little alcove,
and there appears to
be an opening here in
front of bricks.
So the idea will be that we will
layer canvas over top of
one another with a map
of the bottom.
And in the simplest example,
there will be one layer over
the top of another, just
as in Photoshop.
And the top will be the gray.
It'll be the fog of war.
And you can only see what you
have already explored.
So if Bruce moves down this
path here, the gem will be
able to reveal this
corridor to him.
And as you travel through the
game, you'll be able to view
more and more.
Now, again, this is imminently
hackable.
You could go and figure out
where this image resides, and
go and download it, and cheat
it and look ahead.
But that's like being the
banker in Monopoly, and
getting interest free loans.
Which I did as a child,
and I regret it.
I don't regret it,
but I'm ashamed.
FRASIER: But I definitely see
that issue, and I do think
it's pretty valid.
I think what we are exploring
here is sort of potentially
something as interesting as a
lot of the social game that's
already happening, the stuff
that Zynga and people like
that are doing.
Those games you're changing
numbers in the database
somewhere and managing
your farm.
It doesn't really appeal to me
at all, but I love the idea of
being able to play
a game of chess
against other human being.
Can you imagine all of the
poker games that could be
happening out there as people
are playing games against
other human beings the way
nature really intended.
So I think that a lot of these
issues are definitely going to
come back to the foreground over
time as it stops being
just a bunch of individual
people just getting together
with their existing social
connections.
You could imagine open forums
where people who love a
certain kind of game could
be dropped into
a game right away.
They can start playing with
DM, you could see the
reputations of the DM.
You could bring your characters
from one game to another.
I mean the possibilities
of this are endless,
and scale up forever.
CHARLES: And the security issues
are significant and
important, and I think
we'll address them.
But right now adding features
and working on stability are
the priorities.
And we're trusting people that
they're not going to ruin
their own experience.
At some point we'll go back and
lock everything down, I'm
sure to an extent.
FRASIER: Yeah, but I think
it's addressing a whole
paradigm that actually works so
with what Google+ is, and
what the hangouts are all about,
which is instead of
updating My Farm, let's get
together, hang out, let's play
a game, and let's have a shared
environment of space
that supports that and really
encourages that.
JONATHAN BERRY: Yeah, that's
a really good point.
The way we describe hangout
apps, in general, is we say
hangouts are social
by default.
You don't hang out
by yourself.
And, hanging out with one
or two people is not so
interesting.
But it's when you have this room
of nine other people that
things get really interesting,
and the
conversation starts flowing.
And hangout Apps, by extension,
are social, by
nature, by default rather.
And so games that require you
to have a bunch of people
hanging out and doing stuff
together is the model that we
want to build.
So table games, obviously,
are perfect for that.
And they have a lot of
engagement, long time spans,
and so this is a good model.
I think a lot of times we get
solved problems. And for you
guys building off the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
probably is the first thing.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: And then the
other thing is that because
it's Google+, you know who
you're dealing with, and
there's a reputational aspect
there, already.
It's sort of like if
somebody's really--
it's always funny to get hung up
on security in a game that
is ultimately about shared
imagination.
CHARLES: But for us, building
the app is a game, too.
So we want to do it as perfectly
as we possibly can.
So you run into some sort of
problem, and you think,
awesome, a problem.
You don't think, ah
crap, a problem.
So doing all of that is going
to be just fun to do.
Right now every time we talk
about the app, we get gamers
going, oh and can we do this?
Oh, we want Tarot cards,
oh and I want a deck.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: Oh, and we
were thinking about, oh you
could learn a site on the maps,
and then you could do--
CHARLES: I don't think I've seen
a single comment that's
been, my players cheat.
I want you to make sure that
they don't mess with their
dice rolls.
It's all, I want to upload this,
I want to do a video,
give me tokens that look
like little orcs.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: I want to
play music through the
plug-ins, so that everybody
has a soundtrack.
JOSHUA: That's actually
in the roadmap.
FRASIER: And there's the face
tracking, so you can give
people costumes when they show
up, give them a little helmet
or elf ears.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: Everybody's
supposed to be somebody,
there's always the classic
middle school role-playing
where you forget what gender
your character is, you keep
switching back and forth.
It's like, no, you'd actually
put on the hair and makeup and
everything, and actually
be able to do it.
No that would be awesome.
CHARLES: So that's an
interesting thing.
There's a real balance there,
because a lot of people, I
include myself among them, don't
like to see a lot of
visuals, because I like it all
to happen in my imagination.
It's like watching a movie once
you've read the book.
You imagine what Harry Potter
looks like, and you go see the
movie, and you're like,
that's not him.
And then you go back and reread
the book, and you can't
imagine m the way you
did originally.
He looks like the movie actor.
Oh, there's a little bit of my
imagination thrown away.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: You can
definitely explore the
costuming with an extension
that's running in parallel for
the people who--
JOSHUA: Yeah, optionally.
One of the things that we we're
actually exploring was,
besides the face tracking
effects with the visuals is a
kind of augmented reality
condition marker.
So that if your character was
in a confused state, or was
poisoned, you would have
a floating green
skull above your head.
FRASIER: You can see how many
hit points you have left.
The GM at a glance can
see who needs to be
beaten up a little harder.
ALLEN: Well but even better is
that depending on how many hit
points you've lost, your face
gets bloodier and bloodier.
CHARLES: Ending with little Xs
over your eyes when you die.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: We support
multiple overlays.
You can actually continue
to add scar tissue
to people as they--
JOSHUA: Right, but you can
only still tie them to
something being tracked,
right?
You can't put them
static, yet.
So if I move my head, my HP
camera would move around in
circles or something.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: Right this
second you can do it with the
set Avatar, and then just
bounce that state.
Everybody updates, because the
set fish tracking overlay
attaches it to your stream, and
then whatever you do gets
seen by everybody else.
But set avatar actually is
individual for each client.
So I'll make an extension that
turns you into an Android, but
you don't even know
that happened.
JONATHAN BERRY: I think Alan
just loaded up his caption
app, attention rather.
ALLEN: Yeah, but it's
not working today.
CHARLES: Well we did at one
point, we're redoing it now,
is little tooltips over
top of your icon.
So when you start the game, your
avatar appears as a small
icon on the map.
And when you roll over, you get
a little tool tip over top
that shows some text.
JONATHAN BERRY: I think also
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] made a lower
thirds extension that could be
very useful, that has your
character's name
at the bottom.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: Do you guys
have orientation for your
characters?
I realize that fourth edition
D&D doesn't do orientation.
JOSHUA: Yeah there's a right
click contextual menu options
on the tokens.
So you can rotate them or
increase or decrease the size
or lock them so nobody
else can move them,
that kind of thing.
JONATHAN BERRY: I think we have
some questions prepared.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, we have a
couple questions, although you
guys answered most of them
through your chatter.
That's the best way to do it.
So I realise you guys have been
developing since about
the beginning of the Hangouts
apps, the Hangouts API.
And it was pretty rough,
especially at the beginning.
Would you mind telling us about
some of the interesting
challenges you overcame
as you were developing
the Tabletop Forge?
JOSHUA: Sure, so one is,
obviously, the limited size of
the state object.
So when I first was attempting
to do this when you added a
map, I was trying to figure out
a way-- well I just want
to share the whole image through
the state when it was
a 100K image.
Obviously, even as a
data URI, that just
wouldn't fit in there.
So that's when I came up with
the concept, well if it's a
URL, I can just share that
URL, instead, through the
state object, and have everyone
add that to the DOM
through that method, rather than
having to fit 100K object
in there every time.
That was definitely
a challenge.
It's actually still a challenge,
because the state
object doesn't refresh--
I mean it's pretty fast, but
sometimes there's a little bit
of a lag in there.
So you have to account
for that some times.
CHARLES: I think I found one of
my problems was balancing
the number of times I
wanted to refresh
from the state object.
And I periodically get into
these little infinite loops
where I would update state
object, and the state object,
because it was updated would
tell me to update again, and
over, and over, and over,
and around again.
And the problem is that I
develop by myself, and I play
with others.
And so all of a sudden you're
developing with nobody in the
room, and suddenly you put other
people in the room, and
their doing all sorts of things
that you couldn't
possibly have debugged
for yourself.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: Well
you're lying.
Jonathan's saying that you don't
hangout by yourself,
except developers.
I hangout by myself
all the time.
CHARLES: That's like looking
in a mirror.
That is actually a problem that
I ran into, that I didn't
find a really good solution to
it was that I wasn't able to
reproduce, in that way,
the live environment.
My dev environment was
inherently different from the
live environment.
And I could've stolen my wife's
computer, and join her
to the Hangout.
And as long as she
wasn't using her
computer, it worked fine.
It would just be an empty
room, but without hack.
FRASIER: And I think early on
some of the problems we had
was that there wasn't a lot
of control over the actual
hangout environments.
We had a lot of problems being
able to get the video to show
in the same kind of way that
the Hangouts work.
So with this, you see that
whoever is talking shows up as
the big picture.
And so before, all you had was
the thumbnail, and you had no
way to control the big window.
But a lot of it was us nagging
the API team to give us more
and more control over
the different
elements of the interface.
And now I think everything
that we want
to do it is in there.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
FRASIER: So thank you for
being so receptive.
CHARLES: I would like to add
the app to the on-air
functionality.
I think that would be great.
I would like to be able to play
the game and have people
watching the game while other
players are in there.
FRASIER: Yeah, I mean this is
the big idea that we've been
thinking about.
Wouldn't it be cool to pull
together a lot of the Google+
celebrities, and have a big role
playing game with them
all at the same time, and bring
in some celebrity DMs,
and do that as a
Hangout on-air?
I think it would
be really fun.
Right now there's no way that
we can think of to actually
drag this functionality through
into hangouts on-air.
JONATHAN BERRY: So you can
screen share on hangouts
on-air, right?
WILLIAM THOMPSON: Yeah, people
have been doing that.
JONATHAN BERRY: And then you
can an app in your hangout.
So is that what you want to
do, or is it a little
different than that?
WILLIAM THOMPSON: So the screen
share isn't quite as
instantly updating as putting
the app native to it.
JONATHAN BERRY: Yeah, you
got to do the on-air.
Is that what you're
thinking, though?
FRASIER: Yeah, so for example,
right now we can't actually
access the app in this hangout
and actually display it out in
a way to the audience as
watching this hangout.
JOSHUA: We kind of can.
So when Charles loaded it
earlier, if you saw, I
actually was able to make roll
that showed on his screen.
So we access it all locally.
One person has to screen share
from one person's view, but it
does sort of work.
FRASIER: Right, and so you can
imagine that it would need to
be some sort of separate version
that's presented as
part of the hangout on-air, and
then the various players
have their own access
to it and their own
version of it as well.
Its just you've got one
extra player that's
just watching, right?
CHARLES: Also because of the
lag, as Josh was pointing out
at the beginning of this, I had
to turn off my main video,
because re-sharing the video
was causing lag.
And you never see the face of
the person who's sharing it.
JENNY MURPHY: We need an
additional headless view.
Because for cases like the game,
you're going to have to
potentially have different
visibility for your view
versus the player's views.
JONATHAN BERRY: Well, and you
can insert the video canvas
into your app.
So you could insert back in.
JOSHUA: Yeah, we have that
there, but that's he was
talking about.
He had to minimize it.
Because once he started screen
sharing, it just got really--
I mean that's pretty
insensitive to put
that video up there.
CHARLES: Yeah, having a main
video in there's good.
FRASIER: Yeah, I mean I think
the solutions that we've
thought about is more stripping
it down, and having
one video that just contains the
game information happening
in it, and then having that act
like a virtual camera that
contains that information.
And then whoever is the director
of the show is
switching back and forth
as required.
If someone rolls a die, we'll
switch back over, and show the
die getting rolled, then
we go back to the game.
So it's just a whole other
layer of complexity.
But I think it would be
really interesting.
I would love to play a game with
Vick and Sergey and all
those guys.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: We'll leave
them with shortened shields
too, if possible.
I would think.
FRASIER: Are they really
game geeks?
Let's find out.
CHARLES: And there's lots of
guys in the gaming industry
that you would never read
outside of a con that you can
play with, or that you
can watch play.
It would be really cool to watch
Wil Wheaton and Monte
Cook and Peter Atkinson
play D&D.
So if they were going to play
the game, they're going to
play it on Hangout, maybe.
But still, nobody's ever going
to see it unless they save it
and post it to YouTube.
Really cool if those guys got
together and played a game, or
if there's a big game at a
convention, and you could just
watch it live.
That would be awesome.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: So everybody's
writing comments
on the post that can
feed into the DM.
CHARLES:Yeah.
FRASIER: That's great, writing
some of the ideas into the
story, that's awesome.
It's like a big hive-mind.
CHARLES: Well that's what I was
thinking, actually, Frasier.
In that game that we're playing
in Arcane Apocalypse
that when you open
your mind to--
when you cast this magic spell
to scribe to see what's going
on the world, we
could just pull
stuff out of the comments.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: Run an entire
Dungeon that's all
freestyle from the comments?
JOSHUA: Yes, sure, that
would be awesome.
FRASIER: You have a shared
environment of people creating
things ahead of time as you go,
and even the DM doesn't
even know what's
going to go on.
It's like improv.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: Like, oh
my God, look at that.
That'd be really fun.
CHARLES: This elf is
coming towards you!
WILLIAM THOMPSON: All right,
next question.
JENNY MURPHY: Next question,
you've already alluded to this
a little bit, especially when
you showed us the fog of war
and mentioned a couple other
things you were planning to
add, but where do you plan
to take this game?
What are some interesting
things on your road map?
JOSHUA: OK, so we do want to
integrate with some 3rd party
sites using OAuth.
So there's a popular campaign
management site out there
called Obsidian Portal that does
allow OAuth to keep track
of your notes and your
character sheets
and stuff like that.
So basically you'd be able to
pull that information in a
hangout, so that between
hangouts you can have this is
what happened since last time.
This is our log of our
adventures, and not have to
replicate all that functionality
within the
hangout app itself.
Yeah, Charles talked about
the fog of war.
So we definitely want
some more advanced
mapping type of features.
We have to be careful, because
a lot of people want things
like super advanced line
of vision and automatic
calculating, distances
between objects.
And while having a computer is
great to let you do stuff,
that stuff is not on
the table top.
So we have to walk a fine line
that we don't turn into
computer game, and keep it close
to the actual playing
game experience.
CHARLES: And again, as I said
at the beginning, we're not
developing for a game.
We're developing for a
whole host of games.
This is like building an
app for board games
or card games, right.
The more you make specific
things that work for specific
games, the less time
you're spending on
everybody else's game.
So line of site is very
important for D&D, but really
irrelevant for things like a Ars
Magica or Apocalypse World
that are abstract
combat in a way.
We want to build things like
a deck of cards you
can draw out of.
A set of dice that you could
roll, random number generators
that just cover things that
we have never thought of.
For example, one game that I was
playing, when we came to a
town, Greg Christopher who was
GMing would pick, randomly,
two of the seven deadly sins
to define what kind of
conflict was going
on in the town.
And so he was like, OK well
I got pick a number
between one and seven.
I said just roll a
seven sided die.
And I hadn't actually programmed
a seven sided die,
but I built the RegEx so that it
could do any random number.
So he goes, oh OK, 2D7,
boom, and it worked.
And we want to have that kind
of flexibility, so that
anybody can come in with any
game that we've never seen
before, that we've never
played before, and
it works for them.
FRASIER: I mean right now you
could go and create a map
that's a chessboard, you could
upload a bunch of the tokens
that are the pieces, and you
could almost out of the box
have a game of chess with
somebody, right, with no real
modifications even to
the environment.
I mean as long as you have the
picture of the chess board and
the right tokens for pieces,
then you got
yourself a chess game.
Yes, when I go to the bathroom,
Charles could be
moving pieces around,
but it's all that's
all possible, right?
CHARLES: How did you
get four queens?
I don't remember that.
Well that's the compromise
between
flexibility and security.
And it's not necessarily a
technical issue always.
Some of it is just that you want
to leave it open ended.
So sure you, can cheat and
move your pawns back when
somebody's in the bathroom.
So that's the downside, but the
upside is that you could
take this RPG game and turn it
into a chess board, or a
checkers board.
Or you could play Backgammon
on it, in theory.
You could play pretty much any
game you wanted, but you're
not going to have the rules
programmed in preventing you
from cheating.
So it's a compromise.
I think one of the other things
Josh and I were talking
about is that at some point,
this is going to get to level
of wanting to do a Kickstarter
around it.
And get some design people
in and really get all the
functionality that we want,
organize it all, put it out to
the community, and see
who's willing to
kick in a couple bucks.
Because we're not making
any money off of this.
I certainly started building
this, because my Ars Magica
game, which was in Frasier's
living room actually, fell
apart because we lived in a town
of 30,000, and I think
there's seven gamers and
we were three of them.
The moment we came online we
found 20,000 other people that
we can play with, and there
was always somebody free.
And so I built this so I could
continue my games.
And I'm happy to share it
with everybody else.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
So we actually have a question
from the comment stream.
Christian asks, are you
planning to include
functionality for saving
log as other assets.
For example, the Google Docs
or Google Drive or possibly
pulling a content from there?
JOSHUA: Yes, so in early alpha
versions of the app, we
actually were saving stuff to
Google App Engine in a data
store and pulling that back in
to, basically, as you join the
hangout, you could choose
a previous session.
And whatever map state it was,
or where the tokens where, all
that would get replayed
at the current state.
And that's almost ready
for this version.
It's just that when we went from
alpha to beta-- but it's
still really kind of alpha--
we redid the whole
engine of how we
stored those JSON objects.
So we have to rewrite the code
to sync that to App Engine, or
we might do MySQL database.
It really doesn't matter
on the back
end, but that is coming.
CHARLES: I was doing
my own MySQL.
There's also Obsidian Portal
that Josh eluded to earlier
that really does that.
It's a site where you can
create a wiki for your
campaign, and you can
make, essentially a
blog for your campaign.
So we could be writing sessions
back to that for
people who use that.
It's a question of finding the
best way to do it, finding a
giant data store.
One way that I've been
considering doing it is
something like Dropbox or Google
Docs, where you could
just go in preload.
You do all your maps, you
do your tokens, and your
pictures, and so on,
and so forth.
And you just drop them
into a Dropbox.
And then when you're in the
game, you have a tool window
where you could just go and
click, click, click, click,
and load up your images directly
from your shared
folder somewhere.
That's the best way to do that,
we haven't figured that
technically yet.
FRASIER: Yeah, and when that
used to exist in the
functionality, it was pretty
great, because then we could
quickly review what happened
last week.
I don't know if you've ever
played, and you don't remember
the names of people that you
meet and things like that.
There was a certain continuity
that you could go back and go,
who was that person that I
stabbed in the back again?
Oh right, because you'll write
down notes as you do it.
Fraser stabs Charles
in the back.
CHARLES: It's basically a search
of a Twitter stream
that we all contributed to.
FRASIER: Yeah, and hash tags
and things like that, so I
that all was very cool,
and it would be great
to have that back.
CHARLES: That's part of the
whole merging my work with
Josh is, which is an
ongoing process.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: I
had a question.
The 1D7 is an example of
something you can do in
virtual space that you can't
do in real life.
It's a better than being
there moment.
Do you have another
one of those?
Just something that happened
that's unique?
CHARLES: Yeah, there's a game
called Mouse Guard that's
based on a comic book.
And the role playing game was
written by Luke Crane.
So it's built on his burning
wheel system.
And instead of having one big
die, a 20-sided of die or
12-sided die, you have a whole
bunch of, basically, coin
flips, 2-sided dice.
And you can't up the number that
were successes versus the
number that were failures.
So it's a D2 basically.
It's a coin which is a D2.
And on the table, what you do
is, you normally don't carry a
bunch of coins to the table.
You roll D6s, and one, two,
three, counts as a failure,
and four, five, six, counts
as-- so it's a hack.
The dice version is a hack.
In Hangouts you just roll D2s,
and it works perfectly.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: Yeah, you can
roll arbitrary numbers.
Yeah, I remember with the Star
Wars role playing game, you
always ended up with giant
fistfuls of dice, and it would
take us forever just
to add them all up.
And so, that's a cool point.
JOSHUA: Yeah, we actually do
support what, for those kinds
of systems, a lot of times
you're comparing them to a
target number.
So I'm rolling 10 dice, and
anything bigger than a four
counts as a success.
So our syntax does, you can do
10D6 greater than or equal to
four, and then anything that
was a rolled greater than a
four, it highlights and then
counts those successes for you
automatically.
So it saves you a little
bit of time.
FRASIER: I mean it's
that same thing.
If you've ever played Catan or
Carcassonne or things like
that, but on your iPhone
or your iPad
and things like that.
And it's just like you can burn
through games in minutes.
You play a game of Catan, and
you're done in 20 minutes,
when normally a bunch of people
sitting around a room,
it's going to take you five
hours to get through a game.
It's just because all of the
mechanics is all just getting
done so quickly.
The game is getting set up, the
dice are being rolled, and
it feels very similar to that.
Which is all of that it, roll
the dice, oops it fell on the
table, oops, got to pick
it back up again.
Is that cocked, is it not?
That all is just like boom,
dice get rolled
really fast. It's good.
That part has really smoothed
out the game play so much.
And like what you're saying,
those the games where you've
just got these great big fist
fulls of dice, you got to add
them all up and you've got to
add all those modifiers, and
this is so much better.
CHARLES: And the user ability
and the user interface and
making sure that those things
happen quickly and smoothly,
that's going to be a big part of
our project going forward.
And I think that when we get to
the Kickstarter, certainly
that's going to be a big
priority for me, anyways.
As the GM, you end up spending
a lot of time uploading a new
map, or where do I put
that thing, oh I got
to scale that properly.
If you could do all that before
the game, and just dump
it somewhere, and then be able
to click, click, click, and
pull it in, push it out.
That will make the game so much
easier for everybody.
Fog of war, OK, I'll put my map
up, but I don't have to
worry that you guys are going
to see thing that you can't
see, because I'll just
block it out.
FRASIER: And I think that's
really the fundamental
philosophy that's driving the
whole process, as we mentioned
before, which is start from
maintaining that core
essential game experience that
you play with your friends,
that you hang out, that it's
all interacting and social,
and then support and remove
all of the scutt work, the
things you don't really enjoy
doing as you play your game.
So you can get at the essential,
which is the shared
experience.
The rules of the games often
get in the way of the play.
But in many cases they're
necessity, and so all of the
things that arr hard and slow
and complicated, we can get
that out of the way.
We ca just have a
really fun game.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
Well believe it or not, we're
actually running out of time.
45 minutes flew by.
So does anyone have any closing
comments or thoughts
they'd like to add
before we close?
FRASIER: What was your first
game that you played?
WILLIAM THOMPSON: We were just
talking about this before we
got started.
The first role playing was
actually the old blue Advanced
D&D box set, it was this
was the one after the
three little books.
I have that one as
my first one.
FRASIER: That was the right?
It was the expert set.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: The expert or
something, and you started
with The Keep on the
Borderlands,
was the first one.
And then after that, we did
a whole bunch of things.
I ended up playing
tons of Mirth in
Middle Earth role playing.
And then we added the spell
caster rules to it, because we
wanted better spells and
better criticals.
And then we got into
Twilight 2000.
It was a lot of riding around
in Eastern Europe in planes,
shooting at bad guys.
It was great.
I think that was when I finally
had an encyclopedic
knowledge of firearms.
Ad unfortunately it stops in
high school because I stopped
playing Twilight 2000, and
moved on to other stuff.
I have all weapons
before like 1993.
JONATHAN BERRY: This is a skill
I hope to use one day.
JENNY MURPHY: We'll finish
our time machine,
and go back to 1993.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: Yes
I'm ready for the
apocalypse in 1993.
And more recently we've been
playing the rebuild of Gamma
World which is fairly nuts.
I remember playing the original
Gamma World, and it
was crazy, but it was sort
of serious crazy .
And the new Gamma World
is just crazy.
It's a lot of fun.
JENNY MURPHY: Nothing?
JONATHAN BERRY: I'm going
to pass on this one.
FRASIER: We can't suck
you into a game then?
JONATHAN BERRY: Most of my role
playing experience has
actually been in the last
year working at Google.
JENNY MURPHY: Funny how that
happens, isn't it?
JONATHAN BERRY: Yeah.
JENNY MURPHY: I'm also
pretty casual myself.
So you'll usually
find me playing
Carcassonne or Settlers.
But occasionally, especially if
I'm at a gaming con, or I'm
with some friends who are more
into it, I'll definitely pick
up the dice.
And I've played a lot of fifth
edition and some fourth
edition, I believe.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: Actually, and
the other thing we used to
play is Call of Cthulhu.
FRASIER: Awesome.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: That was how
we dragged our girlfriends
into playing role
playing games.
FRASIER: And that's actually the
game we've been thinking
would be a really good intro
public game, because it's
horror, the rules are really
simple, there's a lot of stuff
there that a lot of people
would really enjoy.
And you could genuinely
freak out the players
if you did it right.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: It was
all about atmosphere
when you play it.
We'd turn the lights low, we'd
light some candles, and we had
some friends that were pretty
good at chanting strange
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JENNY MURPHY: Cool, okey doke.
So we are actually completely
out of time now.
So we're going to
call it a week.
Thank so much for joining us.
WILLIAM THOMPSON: Absolutely,
and this is a
totally awesome project.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes, and we'll
be following this very
closely, and maybe you guys
would like to join us again in
the future.
CHARLES: Yes, six months
from now it'll be
unrecognizable, hopefully.
JENNY MURPHY: Hopefully
in a good way.
OK, well thanks again.
CHARLES: Thank you!
WILLIAM THOMPSON: We'll see you
whenever we do this again.
JENNY MURPHY: In a couple
of weeks we'll be
doing another session.
So, all of you, we'll see you
in a couple of weeks.
Bye!
CHARLES: All right, bye.